Timothy Evans was no saint and there was good
reason for the police to suspect him of murdering
his pregnant wife and baby daughter.
He and said wife, Beryl, had a long history
of angry quarrels including witnesses stating
that the couple occasional came to blows with
one another.
Seemingly a constant source of argument was
Beryl being upset with Evans for heavy drinking
and wasting their money on it and Evans angry
with Beryl for poor housekeeping and her own
mismanagement of their finances.
Nonetheless, the couple had a daughter in
1948, Geraldine, but this, too, was apparently
a strain.
When Beryl became pregnant again in 1949,
unable to afford to care for a second child,
the couple decided to obtain an illegal abortion.
When the initial inquiry began, Evans certainly
appeared guilty of murdering his wife and
future daughter.
After all, the first the police heard of it
was when Evans walked into a police station
on November 30, 1949 and confessed that he
had killed Beryl… albeit accidentally by
giving her something from a bottle that was
to abort the baby.
As for his daughter, he told them he had placed
her with another family after the death of
Beryl.
After his confession, the police began an
investigation.
But when they looked for Beryl’s body in
the sewer drain near 10 Rillington Place,
where Evans claimed he stashed it, they didn’t
find it.
Not only was there no body there, but it required
three men to remove the manhole cover for
the drain.
Needless to say, they weren’t buying the
story.
Confronted with the information that the body
was not where Evans said it was, Evans gave
them a rather different tale.
He claimed his downstairs neighbor, former
police officer John Christie, offered to perform
an abortion for the couple and, after discussing
it, they agreed to have him do it.
According to this version of the story, Evans
went to work the day of the procedure on November
8, 1949 and, when he returned, Christie told
him the abortion had gone horribly wrong and
Beryl had died.
Evans then stated that Christie offered to
dispose of the body and arrange for a family
to care for Geraldine while Evans got out
of town for a while.
Ultimately Evans agreed to the plan, leaving
the baby Geraldine with Christie and going
to stay with relatives in Wales.
With this new story in hand, the police began
a new search for the body of Beryl, for a
time coming up empty despite a search of Evans
and Christie’s home.
Finally, on December 2nd, Beryl’s body was
found, as was Geraldine’s- discovered in
the back garden of the residence where Evans
and Christie lived.
The cause of death of both was the same – strangulation.
When confronted by police about the fact that
not only had his wife not died as a result
of a botched abortion, but had been been strangled,
and his baby daughter had also been found
strangled, Evans changed his story once again.
This time, he told the police he’d murdered
Beryl first after an argument about money
and later murdered Geraldine in the same way
before skipping town.
Evans’ trial began on January 11, 1950,
and he was convicted a few days later of murdering
his daughter.
He was not charged with the murder of his
wife because if Evans had been found innocent
or if a mistrial had occurred, by not lumping
the two charges together, the prosecutors
could re-try him on the second charge of murdering
his wife.
Concerning his conviction, the jury only deliberated
for 40 minutes.
His sentence of death by hanging was carried
out on March 9, 1950.
He was 25 years old at the time.
So where’s the problem in all of this?
After all, he confessed to the murders.
Well, it turns out Evans seemingly actually
had nothing to do with the deaths of his pregnant
wife and daughter, other than trusting the
wrong man.
You see, three years after Evans was executed,
John Christie was evicted from the house in
question and the tenant who lived in Evans’
former section of the home, one Beresford
Brown, was given access to the now vacant
section of the house in March of 1953.
While Mr. Brown was hanging a radio in the
kitchen, he discovered a hidden door that
had been covered with wallpaper.
Behind it was a pantry.
Inside the pantry, he found three bodies-
all women, and all strangled.
It turns out that John Christie was a serial
killer of women, with his preferred way to
kill them being strangulation.
Further, investigation revealed that when
he performed the murders for which Evans was
ultimately blamed, he had already killed two
women.
The first was a young woman named Ruth Fuerst
in 1943- a prostitute that he confessed to
strangling on a whim while having sex.
The second woman, Muriel Amelia Eady, was
a co-worker he confessed to killing in 1944
after luring her to his house with a promise
of a mixture that would cure her of bronchitis.
Instead, he tricked her into inhaling burning
coal fumes, with the carbon monoxide present
ultimately causing her to lose consciousness.
After this, he raped and strangled her.
Both of these bodies were found buried in
the garden and had been missed by police when
they searched for the body of Beryl three
years before.
Christie’s next victims were Beryl and,
it is thought, the baby Geraldine.
However, interestingly, he denied he murdered
Geraldine, despite Geraldine having been killed
by strangulation seemingly in the exact same
way as Beryl.
It is worthy of explicitly mentioning again
here that Evans had been convicted of only
the murder of Geraldine.
Had Christie confessed to murdering her, this
would have shed even more negative light on
the police’ investigation and the trial
of Evans.
In any event, after the deaths of Beryl and
Geraldine, Christie confessed to murdering
four more women, the first of which was his
wife, Ethyl, in late 1952.
In the following three months, he went on
a murder-spree, killing a prostitute named
Kathleen Maloney, then a woman known as Rita
Nelson who was in town visiting her sister,
and finally one Hectorina MacLennan, who he
had been helping, along with her boyfriend,
find a place to live in London.
In all three cases, he appears to have first
exposed the women to carbon monoxide until
they passed out, then raped and strangled
them, and finally wrapped the bodies in blankets
exactly as Beryl Evans’ body had been handled
after her death.
So why did Evans confess to killing his wife
and child and how did investigators miss the
two other bodies on the premises when searching
for Beryl?
To answer these questions a commission was
formed to investigate the matter.
This first inquiry, however, as had happened
during Evans’ trial, ignored important evidence
and ultimately raised more questions than
it answered.
In response, in 1955, private citizens petitioned
the Home Secretary to look into the matter
further, while at the same time a book on
the subject, The Man on Your Conscience, by
Michael Eddowes, was published.
Some time later, journalist Ludovic Kennedy
also wrote about Evans in Ten Rillington Place.
In the end, this second investigation finally
seems to have gotten to the bottom of what
happened.
To begin with, while Evans’ first story
and confession appear to have been genuine
(and seemingly concocted as a way to protect
Christie from any blame in what Evans at the
time thought was just an accident), the second
confession- the one he made directly after
he apparently was first finding out that his
wife had been murdered and his baby girl was
not safe with another family, but also dead-
that one was made under threats of violence
from the police officers around him, who dictated
the confession to him and forced him to sign
it.
They also don’t appear to have been able
to extract that confession until many hours
into the interrogation, which extended well
into the early morning hours the next day
after it started.
This was something Evans would later claim
in court, continuing to profess his innocence,
including directly before his execution.
Nobody believed him.
As to why the police were so convinced he’d
done it, this appears to primarily be because
of their own gross incompetence and inability
to come up with a motive for why Christie
would have done it, as Evans claimed.
On the former point, when the police searched
for the body of Beryl, their search methods
left something to be desired, including not
bothering to check the wash-room the first
time, nor bothering to excavate the small
garden (approximately 5×4 meters) when their
initial incomplete search turned up nothing.
It was also later noted that a human femur
was being used to prop up a trellis that was
in plain sight in the garden, though it’s
not clear from the evidence at hand whether
this was there when the police were originally
investigating or was placed there after.
(Christie would later state that almost directly
after the police left the first time, a dog
dug up the skull of one of his former victims.)
On top of this, when the officers did eventually
find the bodies of Beryl and Geraldine, they
told Evans exactly where they were found and
how the murders were accomplished.
Even moderately competent interrogators would
have withheld this information to get Evans
to admit to it in his confession.
An even bigger problem was that the police
officers involved also intentionally suppressed
critical evidence in the case- that workmen
who had repaired the roof of the home in question
shortly after the murders stated that the
washroom that the police eventually found
the bodies of Beryl and Geraldine in had not
contained any bodies whatsoever after Evans
had supposedly stashed them there.
Thus, sometime between the murders and, critically,
after Evans had left town, the bodies had
been moved into the washroom.
During the re-investigation, it also came
to light that the police may have not only
suppressed this information, but forced the
workmen to change their story for the official
account.
In essence, the police seem only to have been
interested in evidence that showed Evans was
not only the murderer, but also that no one
else was involved, a particularly interesting
fact given that Christie for a time had been
a member of the police force himself.
Of course, the fact that the bodies were moved
when Evans had been out of town wouldn’t
have necessarily exonerated him, but would
have shown his second confession could not
have been accurate either, and likely called
for further investigation into the matter,
particularly into whether Christie was involved
or was, in fact, the murderer as Evans would
maintain throughout the trial and to the day
he was executed.
Another bizarre thing discovered during this
later investigation was that the police accounts
of their original investigation were contradictory.
Further, they deliberately destroyed critical
evidence pertaining to Evans’ case before
the re-investigation.
Not only that, but they even somehow destroyed
the record book of how and why said evidence
had been destroyed in the first place.
In the end, the original trial came down to
Christie saying Evans was the murderer and
Evans saying Christie did it.
The jury, and the police investigating before
the trial, believed the former police officer,
Christie, and because of it, Evans was convicted
and executed.
However, owing to the facts discovered during
this second inquiry, Evans was pardoned in
1966 and his body exhumed to be buried, not
in the prison graveyard, but rather in a Leytonstone
cemetery.
BentleyThis brings us to the story of one
Derek Bentley.
A few years after Evans was executed for a
crime he did not commit and around the same
time Christie’s true nature was making news,
Bentley and an accomplice, 16 year old Christopher
Craig, committed the crime of burglary.
Unfortunately for Bentley, while fleeing the
scene of the crime, Craig shot and killed
a police officer, one Sidney Miles.
Due to a quirk of English law, Bentley was
just as accountable for the murder even though
he didn’t do it and was fleeing when Craig
shot the police officer.
Needless to say, the 1953 execution by hanging
of the 19 year old Bentley, who was also considered
mentally deficient and whose true crime had
just been that of burglary, did not go over
well with the general public.
Even the sentencing judge, Lord Rayner Goddard,
who had no choice under English law but to
sentence him to death, stated he assumed the
young man would be reprieved.
But in the end, Sir David Maxwell Fyfe chose
not to exercise the Royal Prerogative of mercy
in Bentley’s case, to the exasperation of
many, including Lord Goddard who reportedly
verbally attacked Fyfe for his refusal to
change the boy’s sentence.
As for Craig, who actually killed the officer,
because he was under 18 at the time, he was
not sentenced to death and ended up serving
a 10 year prison sentence before being released.
Bentley himself, though dead, in 1993 was
issued a “royal pardon in respect of the
sentence of death passed upon him and carried
out.”
2EllisFinally, we come to the 1955 case of
one Ruth Ellis.
She was a model who was executed for the murder
of David Blakely whom she was having an affair
with.
Unlike Evans and Bentley, she did in fact
commit the murder in question, but her trial
was marred by the fact that she seemingly
steadfastly refused to allow her lawyer to
competently defend her.
In short, she was determined to be executed.
As to why she killed Blakely, it was revealed
that he had been cheating on Ellis and had
regularly abused her, including one beating
resulting in the loss of her unborn child.
Two weeks after the miscarriage, she shot
and killed him.
When her lawyer suggested she plead insanity,
she simply told him, “I took David’s life
and I don’t ask you to save mine…
I don’t want to live.”
In accordance with her wishes, her lawyer
didn’t really bother to defend her at all,
with even the judge in the case, Justice Cecil
Havers, noting her defense was essentially
“non-existent.”
It should be noted here, however, that this
same judge instructed the jury to ignore the
extreme abuse Ellis received at the hands
of Blakely and her poor mental health as “according
to our law it is no defence…”
The outcry over Ellis’ planned execution
resulted in a petition signed by over 50,000
people asking for mercy in her case, but no
such mercy was given.
Of this, it was written in the Daily Mirror
on the day Ellis’ was executed:
The one thing that brings stature and dignity
to mankind and raises us above the beasts
of the field will have been denied her – pity
and the hope of ultimate redemption.
The medical officer will go to the pit under
the trap door to see that life is extinct.
Then in the barbarous wickedness of this ceremony,
rejected by nearly all civilised peoples,
the body will be left to hang for one hour…
If you read these words of mine at midday
the grave will have been dug while there are
no prisoners around and the Chaplain will
have read the burial service after he and
all of us have come so freshly from disobeying
the Sixth Commandment which says, “Though
shalt not kill”.
Famed American screenwriter and crime novelist
Raymond Chandler would himself ring in, published
in the Evening Standard:
I have been tormented for a week at the idea
that a highly civilised people should put
a rope around the neck of Ruth Ellis and drop
her through a trap and break her neck.
This was a crime of passion under considerable
provocation.
No other country in the world would hang this
woman.
Thanks to outcry over Ellis’ execution,
the Homicide Act was introduced, with the
goal of reducing the number of capital crimes
in the UK.
This did little to satiate the masses who
continued to call for the abolishment of capital
punishment altogether.
In the end, in part thanks to the cases of
Evans, Bentley, and Ellis riling up the public
against capital punishment, it was suspended
in the UK for five years by the Murder (Abolition
of Death Penalty) Act of 1965, which was made
permanent in December 1969, though capital
punishment could still be dolled out until
1998 for the crimes of treason, espionage,
and, oddly enough, arson in a royal dockyard.